(breathing heavily)
- [Interviewer] I'm proud of you.
It takes courage to do this shit.
- Yeah.
I had to muster it up
fucking with a damn tree.
Just round and around.
Then I look down and say,
"Norman, look at you, stupid dude.
You got on Christmas socks in March."
(interviewer chuckling)
- You're wearing green Christmas socks.
- Oh God.
- [Interviewer] All right,
so welcome back, Norman.
- Glad to be back.
- [Interviewer] You were missing,
you were missing in action
for a while here.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You were
supposed to show up a couple
of weekends ago for another update,
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] But you didn't show.
- No, I didn't show up.
- [Interviewer] That told me
exactly what was going on.
Tell me what you've been through.
- Well I'm,
I lost my sister.
Dear, dear sister.
And I'm--
- [Interviewer] She died
in an auto accident?
- Yeah, died in a very
vicious auto accident.
Where her head was severed.
And, you know, um...
- [Interviewer] You went to the funeral?
- Did the funeral and,
that,
that people they just wanna lambast you
and things like that.
Combination of that and
trying to deal with the emotions and
it just, I couldn't take it anymore.
So I went and I got high
as a motherfucker and
I continued to get high.
I think in about,
time is it?
I think in about four hours or
four to six hours I have like 24 hours.
Of course I'm ashamed about it and I think
it was me I put,
I put a little bit too much on myself.
It's not so much that I have that,
that I got this feeling.
It's just that.
Okay, today's okay,
just keep going forward.
I try my best with the positivity
and everything within me.
Even my wherewithal.
And I questioned myself
about five nights ago, "Where
the fuck is your wherewithal?
What the fuck are you doing?
For Christ sakes right now
I have on Christmas socks,
in March."
And some people might deem that funny but
to me, that's a fucking shame.
I'm
I don't use anything as an excuse.
I believe that excuses are skins
of reasons wrapped in lies.
You know,
and basically,
I used because I wanted to.
Because the evidence is, is quite clear.
Driven by
a negative emotional status.
Driven by the loss of a loved one.
This disease itself is unique
enough to come together
and combine itself and fuck me up.
Coming to see you,
I went around the tree for four times
'cause I didn't want to come here.
- [Interviewer] Shame.
- Yeah.
I am,
I'm pretty, probably really not gonna like
any of the comments that are negative
but that's okay.
Because I gotta stay in that mind frame
that it's going to get better.
I remember you were talking about
two steps forward, one step back.
Well God damn it I'm tired of stepping.
(giggles)
You know?
I mean, and, and, and some people may say,
"Well if you're so tired,
why don't you just stop?"
God damn it it's not that damn easy.
- [Interviewer] I think it's
the hardest thing anyone ever
could ever, could ever do.
- You know,
job wise, everything's just fine.
You know,
there wasn't a cloud on the horizon
as "The Big Book of
Alcoholics, Anonymous" states.
And,
unconsciously I knew it,
but it didn't suffice.
Because I got real shaky
before I drank.
I drank first
and then I went and got some crack in.
I've even tried crystal meth.
No I don't really like that shit.
But, you know as
as devastated as I may be,
I gotta pick my head up.
I gotta keep going forward.
I gotta muster up the wherewithal.
I gotta keep praying.
I gotta still keep believing,
I still gotta have that faith.
You know that not
knowing untouchable faith
I have to have it.
You know, I was put in
some situations while I was
you know, running around.
Well they weren't death-defying,
you know, but I had to fight.
You know, and
I don't like to fight because
when I fight,
every time I fight I see my mother
laying in a casket.
And
that's all I remember.
I see mom.
And it's like a
black.
It's just,
this guy told me, he said,
"Man," he said, "Dude,
I've never seen anybody fight like that."
I said, "What happened?"
He said, "What, what happened?"
He said, "Look."
This guy was laying on
the ground with blood
coming out of his ears and his nose.
And I got the hell away from over there.
I could have killed that guy.
All about drugs.
He wanted to hit and I told him no.
I remember that.
(breathing heavily)
What if the situation was turned around?
What if that would have been me?
What if I would've hit
my head on the pavement?
That was all she wrote.
So I just I'm...
At this point I really don't know,
but I know I'm gonna know
soon.
I really thank God for keeping me
with some semblance of
sanity while I was out there.
Last night was the first time
I really had a comfortable sleep.
'Cause I've had to keep one eye open.
I was down here on Skid
Row for a minute and
I went to other places because
I didn't want anybody to find me.
Lo and behold,
when I come back to fucking
Skid Row somebody sees me.
- [Interviewer] You were in a,
they put you up in a place for a while.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I was there.
Yeah. I was in a,
place before I moved into the
the transitional home.
And everything was fine.
You know,
I even seen the drug deal in the motel
go down.
But I'm like, "Hmm,"
it's not that I just
you know brush it off like,
"Shit I got this." No.
I was like, "Wow."
You know, that's something.
No thought.
I'm not going to ask myself "Why?"
Anymore.
Because God damn it, I know why.
Bottom line is, I'm an addict.
The bottom line is I have
a mind as you may see me how
you may, you may see.
People may think that
I'm brilliant as hell.
Yeah, I have some book sense.
And I have some street sense.
But I have to really put this in my mind,
there's times when I have no sense.
My mind has the capability
of fucking me without my permission.
And it's unique that it always does this
when things are okay.
- [Interviewer] You understand
that everyone does though.
- And I'm beginning to
learn that because I seen
a couple of people that
were in recovery with me
at certain times,
and uh
one of the guys, we sat down and
he said, "Man, I'm tired of doing this."
I said, "I am too, but I can't stop."
He said, "You too?"
I said, "Yap"
I said "The moment I said, I wanna stop,
I'll get up, walk down the
street and hear somebody say
Hey, do this, do that."
There's not too much to say.
But I know it's a whole lot to do.
That's the bereavement time.
So I'm okay.
As far as that's concerned.
And then I asked myself last night,
"Do I really want to go back to the job?
Do I really need to go back--"
- [Interviewer] So you
didn't lose the job?
- No.
"Do I really?"
- [Interviewer] How did
you not lose your job?
- Because they knew
about the, I told them.
Flat out about the bereavement.
And,
they said, "Okay,
well
you're new."
But you know, they offered
me some, some time off.
Some bereavement time.
And I was like, "Cool."
I mean, 'cause I worked for a company man
that's really cool.
- [Interviewer] Because
of your sister's death,
they gave you time off.
- Yes.
- [Interviewer] Got it.
- And I'm,
I mean, you know, I went
to the, I think I text you.
I went to the main office
and everybody stood up and applaud me.
I'm like, "What the fuck is going on?"
Well somebody seen my
story and they told someone
and then they told someone,
and they all watched it.
And then a couple of
the ladies were in tears
and they just looked at me like, you know,
"you're so encouraging.
You're such a
breath of fresh air. You're such a light."
(sighs)
Wow.
As many.
- [Interviewer] And you stay alive.
- Many positive things that I receive.
There's times when
the negative dominates.
And this was one of those times.
When you pick it up,
it's gonna get better.
I may have another setback, I don't know.
I'm not going to deal
with a predictable mind.
But I am going to take things
a hell of a lot slower.
A hell of a lot slower to give myself
ample time to
understand
that "Motherfucker you're
not out of the fucking water
just because things are okay."
I know I put too much on myself.
I don't believe ego and pride set in.
Pride only set in when I just
tried to walk down this
damn street and I was,
I was like, "No, man,
I won't disappoint Mark."
But see, it's not
on the bus ride over here,
it's not about disappointing people.
And it's not about disappointing me.
(siren wailing)
It's the fact that I
got to understand that
"Motherfucker you're an addict.
And this shit happens.
(siren wailing)
Maybe there'll come a time
where it won't happen again."
(siren wailing)
We take the bitter with the sweet.
We do what we need to do,
and we keep moving forward.
That's all I can give.
(siren wailing)
- [Interviewer] Losing your sister was
a serious
you know,
it's a hard thing to go through.
And the relapse is
almost
- Inevitable.
(Norman laughing)
- [Interviewer] Inevitable.
I mean, it's just
and you were close to her.
- Yeah, yeah I um...
At the funeral,
it was the first time I thought about it.
I was like, "Oh shit."
And I said a prayer,
and it went away.
It was a fleeting thought.
But that's the motherfucker that got me.
That one right there.
When it came to a point
where it came up in the ear.
- [Interviewer] I think
you called me from Detroit
or Houston where you were.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] For, for...
- And you know, you look at
- [Interviewer] you're doing fine.
- Yeah,
God damn!
If I could turn my damn leg around,
I'd kick my own fucking ass.
You know, with these
Christmas socks on man.
You know, I just I'm...
If I disappointed anyone
I'm not gonna say I'm sorry.
And I'm not gonna apologize.
But I will ask you to keep
continue to pray for me.
For anyone that's going
to say a negative comment,
it's okay.
But always be mindful to see to it
that your own house is in order.
To myself I want to say,
"Forgive yourself, Norman.
Pick your shoes up.
Put them on.
And let's walk again."
(breathing heavily)
- [Interviewer] Just a setback.
- Yeah.
Kids don't know, but they do know.
Oh yeah.
Babies' mothers, both of them called me.
I didn't answer the phone.
My oldest daughter's
mother wants to marry me.
She said, "You're the
only man I've ever loved.
So what if you smoked up three houses
and four cars when we were together?"
I'm like, "What the
fuck you mean so what?"
She's like "Oh yeah,
yeah, I was mad at you,
but I never should've left you."
'Cause she brought me
home, my car was in the
auto repair place and
she picked me up from work
and she took me home to an empty house.
I'm like,
I turned around and looked
at her she just had tears
and she's like, "I can't do it no more."
I said, "Well, what about Alexis?"
She said "imma take care of the baby."
I'm like, "What about me?
I want to see the baby."
"We'll discuss that."
And I'm like, "No, don't leave."
She's like, "Norman I have to."
That was one of those
heart ripping moments of my life.
'Cause I loved her.
And I still love her.
Good woman.
You know, she did,
I haven't looked for my
mom in relationships,
but that motherly instinct, I do.
Because I think it was taken away so,
so quickly.
And um,
she's that type of woman.
Well she'll lay in the
bed, cuddle with me.
And I like that shit.
You know, I'm just a big ass fucking baby.
And I liked that shit.
She would cook food and bring it to me,
you know?
And the fucking thing about it is,
when I first tried to talk to
her, she wouldn't say shit.
I said, "hello." and she
walked right past me.
I'm like "Aye, okay."
I think a couple of days
went by and I said, "hello,"
had seen her again,
she walk right past me.
What the fuck is wrong with her?
So Imma have to put my
macaroni with cheese down.
So I told his little girl
that stayed across the hall
from me in this apartment building
because I was having a house worked on,
I said, "Hey, you know
that big light-skinned
that thick light-skinned girl upstairs?"
She say, "Yeah.
Oh Norman, you like her don't you?"
I say "Yeah."
Well give me some candy and I'll tell her.
I say, "Okay." And I give her some candy.
For four days I sat there
waited at the time that I knew,
she didn't show up.
Lo and behold, one day,
I'm going to check my mail,
and here she comes.
She say, "hm... uh,"
I said, "Pardon me?"
She says, "So you're the
guy who gets the little kids
to do their dirty work, huh?"
I said, "What do you mean?"
"Yeah, huh, that little
girl told me, you like me.
Why didn't you tell me yourself?
You ain't got to nuts to tell me?"
I'm like, "Uh, yeah."
You know, "Now I aint tell
my dad (mumbles) okay."
I said, "Well, hi."
She said "hi."
And that was it.
Beautiful woman.
Inside and out.
I remember when they
said our daughter might not live.
Because she was born at six months.
She'll be 33 in October.
Hmm.
If she could fight to stay alive so can I.
I just realized that shit.
She fought.
Grew up to be a beautiful woman.
A product of me.
(breathing heavily)
Yeah, there's times where I just
spill it, man.
You're the only person
to ever allow me to,
I just feel I'm real
comfortable with you, man.
- [Interviewer] Yeah?
- You know, I'm not,
you know, intimidated by, you know
I don't have that fear with me, man.
Is he a punk? (mumbles)
No, you're just a
comfortable person, and I,
it's not so much that I owed it to you,
but I owe it to myself.
I owe this sitting in this
seat right now I owe it to me.
- [Interviewer] I think
these talks help you.
They help people listening
that are going through similar things,
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And they just help move
they need to go forward in terms of
humans
dealing with these kinds of issues.
Honesty like yours,
and Patrick's, and
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And many of
the other people I interview,
it really just helps.
Because honesty, I
believe is the solution.
- Yeah, and I was talking to
our buddy, our mutual friend, yesterday.
He's like he said, "Dude,
you're the honest motherfucker
I've ever met in my life."
He said, "'Cause you just tell it."
I said, "Well, what do I do?
Sit up and tell a bunch
of fucking lies? For what?
What is it gonna get me?
This is what happened.
This is what the fuck is going on."
You know, it's almost like
smoking a lot of crack
and being in the sun.
You know, you're running around
you trying to find some
shade and you can't.
So you're standing there
sweating like a motherfucker.
- [Interviewer] No, but
there's like the reaction
that all your coworkers had.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] When they saw your videos.
- [Interviewer] It wasn't negative.
- No they were like...
- [Interviewer] It was positive.
- And the president, she was like,
she's like "Can I talk to you?"
I said, "Sure."
We sat talking like about an
hour and a half, you know?
And because I don't put my schooling on
my resume.
'Cause every time I put it on there uh
I've only gotten,
well, I've got six jobs with it.
Disney uh,
is it Ford, General
Dynamics, Disney, Universal.
Who the fuck else was
(mumbles) and Warner Bros.
Because my specific, I have a power resume
and then an administrator resume.
My power resume is with schooling
and everything I've done
as far as computers,
networks,
security implementations
that stuff like that.
My other one is just administrative so,
like when I worked for
The S.Roses, Skid Row Housing Trust,
administrative stuff, office stuff so.
There's a fucking time I went
into a small job (laughs)
with that resume, they like, "Hell no,
you'll take my motherfucking job."
"I don't want your fucking
job." You know? So,
we'll muster it up.
We always do.
- [Interviewer] You got what it takes.
- Yeah.
Yeah. Now got to move (mumbles)
Shit I can't go back to the transition.
(mumbling)
That's it!
So
we'll, we'll.
For Christ's sakes I was in a fucking tent
for the first time in my life.
- [Interviewer] How is living in a tent?
- Oh God.
Fucking rain.
God damn tent sneaking over here,
sneaking over here, sneaking behind me.
I'm like "What the
fuck?" I just laid there.
- [Interviewer] Horrible life.
- Yeah, man I'm like,
"God damn, how did they do it?"
But I stayed in the fucking tent.
(chuckles)
Stayed in the motherfucker.
One thing that was really unique about it.
I was smoking crack and usually
in a closed environment like that,
I would get extremely paranoid.
Not at all.
And I think it was cause I
ran into a buddy of mine.
He left to go to Vegas.
Is this recorded?
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
I can take stuff out though.
- He gave me something.
'Cause he had to go.
And I think that's one of
those things that kept me
okay.
It was
you know?
And then it dawned on me.
"Do you know what the fuck
he did with this shit?
Do you believe you need to
get rid of this motherfucker?"
And I did.
I had it for three days.
But what if I would have got caught?
With drugs and a handgun that's not mine?
And everything would've been pinned on me.
- [Interviewer] That would have been sad.
- I'm sitting in a motherfucking
San Quentin looking
stupid as a motherfucker.
(breathing heavily)
Trying to keep my sanity.
Ah, ooh, damn that was a loud one.
Yap.
Thanks man.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. Thank you man.
- No problem.
No problem at all.
- [Interviewer] You're very brave.
(Norman sighing heavily)
- Gotta keep it in there
it's going to be okay.
- [Interviewer] You're gonna be all right.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] All right Norman.
Thank you for coming in.
- Aint no problem.
- [Interviewer] Thank you for
having the courage to come in.
- No problem.
- [Interviewer] I'm proud of you.
- [Norman] Wow.